kurt is in fort lauderdale florida hi
kurt how are you
hey dave how you doing better than i
deserve man what's up
how you doing um i'm 25. i'm not filled
with my job and i'd like to move out of
my parents house
potentially looking up north but i have
about 50 000 in investments and 90 000
in my savings and i'm blessed to have no
debt um
should i move with the current housing
market situation should i
wait if i should wait should i move some
of that savings money into investment
make some money while i'm waiting
well um the housing market is as you
mentioned is quite hot
in terms of buying a home some areas the
rental market is also closed up
and it's very difficult to find a rental
and so rental prices are going up as
fast as
real estate prices are which there
should be a correlation between the two
that makes sense
um so uh uh
you have done a wonderful job saving
money sir
well done you save all this money or
somebody give it to you
um i'd say about half maybe a little
less than half as an inheritance from my
uncle arrest is all just me saving
um my my father and my mother since i
was young have always told me you know
spend half save half and i just was
never really a big spender so i saved
more than half of that point um
and so i've just been saving uh for i've
been working since i was
you know 16 so i've been saving for a
while now and i'm just
i've always been looking forward to
buying a house and i just was feeling
that was the right time but with this
housing market i'm just
it's kind of shut down my house you said
you might move up north what are you
going to do for a living when you move
well i'd say within the same industry
but right now
i probably don't want analytics that's
what i like to do
right now i do uh more risk management
so encourage you know get into more
analytical so i'm glad we've identified
this because moving up north i think you
had in mind
there's some companies or a company or a
specific job and i think that's the part
we want to work on first is
you're not happy in your job and so you
know
the good news is you're clear you know
what you want to do you have a good idea
of the analytics is where you want to go
i think i determined that where's a good
place to land there then i'd make my
housing decision based on that
okay so do you have a good idea of some
companies or do you have something when
you say move north or you just think in
an area
or are you thinking company that's
pulling you north
um i was thinking more just orlando or
jacksonville because i have uh current
social
networks there um that would you know in
finding a job there's obviously a lot of
within my industry there's a lot in
orlando and jacksonville i was looking
there just to kind of get away from
where i was
where i've currently been where i've
lived all my life you know sure well
that's really good strategy
so kurt i i think you now you need to
take some action steps
and so i've i would begin if you haven't
already you obviously have the social
networks there
i would actually begin to engage those
social networks around those companies
you identified both
friends connections and uh several
companies
that are in your industry at least you
know that it's pretty hot there i'd
start making those connections i'm going
to give you a copy
of my number one best-selling book the
proximity principle which actually walks
you through
step by step how to make those
connections who specifically you're
looking at
because i think if you get really
serious about that curt right now you're
in great shape financially
let's find those opportunities let's go
ahead and get interviews let's land the
gig
and i think the housing decision will
take care of itself because you've been
really smart with your money but let's
land
uh a job and then let's make a housing
decision as a part of that
yeah here's what i i will just add to
that let's take that i'll take the back
end of that strategy
so start working the social networks
you're only a few hours from those towns
get the job landed then go rent an
apartment for six months
then during that six months start
looking for property don't
overpay you there's no reason for you to
have house fever
you can take your time and if the
market's quite hot and you have to
dramatically overpay to get a house then
that's god's saying don't buy a house
right now
just wait take your time sit in that
apartment
in the new job in the new city and take
your time you've got the money you can
pounce
when you see the right thing you're in a
position to do it but don't get the
fever
and pounce especially on your very first
home purchase and overpay
after you've done such a great job
saving money so very very well done sir